hey this is Mel and in this lecture
we're gonna be talking about how we
generate electricity with fossil fuels
so in the previous unit we've been
talking about greenhouse gases and one
of the things that we said is it we
actually burn more fossil fuels to
generate electricity than we do for
anything else even transportation so the
number one source of co2 emissions in
the world is for generating electricity
we're going to explore how that's done
okay so to start with we're going to
talk about how electricity is generated
and in general you need three things to
generate electricity you need a
conductor which is usually a metal you
need a magnetic field and you need
motion so let's talk about these what is
a conductor a conductor is usually
copper but it doesn't have to be but
it's a metal so imagine a wire right so
I've got this copper wire here and when
we when we talk about electricity what
we really mean is we've got the flow of
electrons going down a wire okay
so to get that to happen if I take a
magnet so remember a magnet has a north
cell north side in the south side and
let's say I move this magnet back and
forth what I would if I move this magnet
back and forth what I would notice is
that the little electrons would start
moving down the wire okay and if I move
this back and forth the electrons will
change direction back and forth as well
so the conductor is a metal that allows
the electrons to flow and the motion of
the magnet is what forces the electrons
to move both those things together will
generate electricity
so if I say wanted to power let's say a
light bulb then I would hook this say to
the light bulb okay and as I move this
back and forth the electrons would
actually move down the wire through the
light and they would continue going on a
loop and the light would light up right
so that's electricity so a simple
demonstration is so you may have seen
something like this that this is a
hand-crank generator and inside there
there's a little you see that little
metal cylinder that's got magnet in
there and when I spin the handle okay
the light lights up okay okay so you
need three things to generate
electricity magnetic field the conductor
and in motion so the wires or the
conductor a physical magnet or maybe a
coil wire is the magnetic field but you
need something to move it and the thing
that moves it is usually something
called a steam turbine so a steam
turbine looks like a giant fan and these
the steam turbines sit inside this
housing and steam comes in these holes
and pushes against the the blades of
this turbine and this whole thing spins
around and around and around and on the
other end it's gonna connect to
something that's producing a magnetic
field that will then spin in the same
way that I just spun that little one so
steam turbines can be gigantic and the
reason they have multiple blades as so
as the steam goes through them it it's
the max it's the most efficient way of
trying to capture all the energy from
the steam is they have multiple fan
blades so on in short what happens to
steam comes in
and turns the the blades of the turbine
which then turn a giant version of the
thing I was just holding and that is
what generates electricity so this is
what one looks like in an actual power
plant everything's covered so you don't
there's not much to see but the steam
comes in here there's the the fan blades
would be in here the turbine and it's
spinning this thing which has the
magnetic field and it's generating the
electricity that's the generator here's
another one
steam comes in there here's the
generator and in a big big power plant
they'll have several of these so here
they've got several steam turbines and
then turning generators here okay so
there everything's covered there's not a
whole lot to see if you're actually to
go inside a power plant but in order to
do this you got to make steam in order
to make steam you got to boil water in
order to boil water you need a source of
heat okay so what are some of the things
that we could actually burn well purpose
of this lecture is to talk about fossil
fuels so that's probably where we're in
the start this this is a graph that's
talking about co2 emissions from
different sectors and I just want to
focus on this one right here it says
electricity generation so by burning
fossil fuels we can boil water and this
breaks it down into which fossil fuel we
burn the most and this color right here
is coal so that's number one number two
is natural gas that's thread and then
just a little bit of petroleum so we in
general in this country do not burn oil
to make electricity
we typically burn coal number one and
number two we burn natural gas now in
New Mexico
what's kind of a crappy graphic but it's
only one I got about three-quarters of
all the electricity in New Mexico is
from burning coal and almost all the
rest is from natural gas and we're
starting to see a little bit of
renewables since this slide was made in
2009 since then
renewables has gone up a little bit but
it's still pretty low so let's talk
about coal so what is coal well coal
figure to look at kind of as a black
shiny looking Rock and it starts with
womp so in a swamp you if you kind of
think back to our lecture on dams and
how we said the bottom of a reservoir
gamma reverie and you make a artificial
lake at the bottom you have very little
oxygen right well this is happening
naturally in a swamp so this water down
here is very stagnant and and near the
bottom there's very little oxygen so as
material plant leaves whatever they fall
down they land in the water they sink to
the bottom they actually get preserved
because there's no oxygen down there to
promote decay and so the organic
material builds up and builds up as long
as these swamps stay in existence
eventually the swamp the material from
the swamps is buried and we would call
that peat so you can go to say nursery
or Home Depot wherever you can buy bags
of peat and it looks like kind of old
crappy looking leaves and you put in
your garden as fertilizer but eventually
if over geologic time those that peat
will become buried as weak as it becomes
buried it's good it gets subjected to
pressure and heat and there's this
metamorphism that happens where that
what looks like old dead leaves turns
into this black shiny rock and then we
call it coal and high-quality coal has
been has been buried
you know maybe miles below the surface
and subjected to really high
temperatures for maybe over millions of
years so it's it's seen a lot of heat
and pressure by the time we pull it back
out of the ground but it used to be for
the most part dead plant matter so this
is what a coal seam looks like so you
can imagine this all used to be the
bottom of a swamp long buried subjected
to heat and pressure transformed into
this coal and in order to get to the
coal if I just go back you know you've
got to dig this rock away to get to the
coal down here and sometimes it's that's
really easy like these guys there's just
right below the surface but often it's
not very close to the surface and you
gotta go way down to get it there's a
couple ways we do that one is called
mountaintop removal
and everything you see in this in this
picture is coal you can see all the
black out here and this used to be a
mountain and they started at the top and
they started to remove all the stuff
that was not coal to get down to the
coal and that's what they're doing here
so it's a big operation requires big
equipment big trucks big shovels and
they have to remove a lot of material
for this to be profitable so here's a
mountaintop removal the pictures I'm
showing you here are mostly from the
east east half of the country so
Appalachian region a lot of this so this
was a mountain with trees on it and they
have started at the top and worked their
way down well if you if you do this you
there's a lot of environmental
destruction that's going on as a result
of mountaintop removal a lot of the
material ends up in the rivers you're
wiping out all of the vegetation that
was on top and just from a human
perspective I mean it's a pretty ugly
thing to look at but you can see in this
picture the black is the coal and the
the beige is not coal but they got to
take it all down anyway whether it's
coal or not because they got to remove
the stuff that don't want to get down to
this stuff that they do want so again
all these pictures mountaintop removal
okay so it's a pretty a pretty
environmentally destructive way to
remove coal now the other way of doing
it is underground mines so an
underground mine is you did coals
underground so you drill a hole down get
a tunnel going and this is really
difficult dangerous work you follow that
coal seam and so environmentally it's
actually better for the environment
because you're not taking down a whole
mountain to get to it you're just making
a hole going down there from a workman's
perspective it is a very dangerous job
there's coal dust dangerous equipment
gases coming out and by the way
everything you're mining is flammable so
the accidents happen and coal fires
happen and occasionally we get some
disaster so here's one from 2010 where
25 people in West revenge vert West
Virginia died when there is an explosion
so there's a methane gas buildup and
they ignited and we don't have this so
we have decent amount of safety rules in
this country but if you look at some
other countries like China and they was
you know usually a couple hundred people
a year mining coal it's a bit
underground it's a very dangerous job
and like I said everything you're mining
is flammable so why are we burning coal
in the first place well we just have a
lot of it and as an accident a geologic
history that the United States has a lot
of coal the reason is is for millions of
years we were actually situated in a
place where swamps were very common
widespread over most of the country so
if you ever seen pictures of the
Everglades today you can imagine that
type of environment all across the
United States and so all these places
that are blue are places where we see a
lot of coal deposits because in geologic
time there was just extensive swamps for
they they existed for millions of years
you'll notice that one of those places
happens to be in Northwest New Mexico
ok so we have a pretty good coal deposit
up in here and consequently we have coal
mines in that area and coal-fired power
plants so one of the biggest ones we
have is called the San Juan generating
station there's actually several near
the Four Corners area you can see here
pile of coal here we've got a conveyor
belt system that takes the coal up into
the power plant so a power plant like
this you see there's four chimneys right
that means there's four furnaces that
feed four turbines okay so here we can
see three of them this white that's
coming out is water vapor and a long
time ago we talked about how when you
burn hydrocarbons water vapor as a
byproduct
so then back then we were talking about
it in terms of what makes a cloud so I
actually used a coal-fired power plant
as an example back then so what's coming
out here is
water vapor that's condensing making a
cloud from burning of the coal now
remember the whole reason we're talking
about this is because of greenhouse
gases and as we're burning coal or
producing a lot of carbon dioxide and a
little bit of meal a few other things as
well but you can't see that right you
cannot see the mercury that if there is
any that's coming out you can't see the
NOx all you can really see is the water
vapor but near the Four Corners area
we've got several large generating
stations cold fire power plants because
coal is so plentiful there so here's a
coal mine near Farmington for example
here's another one their Page Arizona
you can see it's got three chimneys
therefore it has three furnaces with
three steam turbines
there's the coal piled up right here
ready to go another picture of it here's
what a here's a pile of coal that's
getting ready to load it up into a
coal-fired power plant so that in this
case the barges are bringing it down
they dump in this pile and they comes up
the conveyor belt and the amount of coal
that is burned and each coal-fired power
plant is kind of staggering so this is a
coal train and it's just a train full of
coal and generally they can be about a
mile long or so and a really big
coal-fired power plant like the one we
have in the four corners can burn
through three to five trains of coal per
day so that gives you some kind of
amount you know it's a staggering amount
of coal that we're bringing through
every single day just to keep generating
electricity so we're gonna watch a
little video here that was put together
by a coal-fired power plant company that
explains very well how it works and
they're going to go through the steps
from the coal going into the into the
power plant until electricity is
generated and it's it's very well done
it's animated one of the things I want
you to pay attention to is they're going
to talk about several technology
geez that they use to clean the exhaust
so in other words as they burn the coal
and exhaust goes up the chimney they
have to clean that before it goes into
the air and they'll talk about several
things that happen to clean that and I
just want to point out that the culpa
the coal-fired power plants in this
country are required to do those things
from our Clean Air Act so so in the past
we talked about air pollution we talked
about we have these regulations for for
air air pollution and other countries
don't necessarily have those right so
the technologies are talking about in
this video are not the same technologies
that you may find say in a in a power
plant in China okay because they don't
have the same stringent
air laws that we do so keep that in mind
let's watch the video
[Music]
our process uses Powder River Basin coal
from Wyoming the sub-bituminous type
coal as a fuel source when the coal
arrives that our plant by train we use a
trencher and a series of long conveyors
to stack coal in our yard move it to
storage silos or send it directly to the
plant we try to keep a thirty seven day
supply of coal about 1.4 million tons on
the pile in our coal yard and up to
forty thousand tons in silos since we
burn as much as thirty eight thousand
tons of coal in a 24 hour period we need
to ensure we have a substantial amount
on hand
[Music]
cold moves into the plant on a conveyor
and is stored in a series of silos each
one leading to a feeder pulverizer and
ultimately to the boiler at plant miller
we have four generating units and each
unit has seven silos feeding into one
single boiler the coal within each silo
falls into a feeder which measures and
controls the flow of coal into a
polarizer inside the pulverizer coal
falls onto a large rotating bowl where
it is continuously crushed by three
large grinding wheels until it becomes
the consistency of baby powder once the
coal is a fine powder it falls off the
grinding Bowl and is carried by warm
primary air maintained at 140 degrees
Fahrenheit
inside the pulverizer to the boiler
through 8 burner lines when the
particles have cold reached the burners
they are mixed with secondary air that
has been preheated to over 500 degrees
to support complete combustion inside
the boiler the combustion of the coal
converts its chemical energy into
thermal energy creating a temperature
inside the boiler of over 2200 degrees
that's enough to heat the water in the
series of boiler tubes to create steam
which moves onto the turbine to power
the next step in our process
[Music]
superheated steam from the boiler which
is approximately 2400 psi and 1,000
degrees travels to the high-pressure
section of the turbine where it creates
the force that turns the turbine shaft
this process causes the steam to lose
temperature and pressure so it must be
sent back to the boiler to be reheated
to 1,000 degrees after reheating the
steam returns to the intermediate
turbine and continues through the
crossover into the low pressure turbines
the force of the steam turns the turbine
shaft which turns the generator rotor at
3,600 revolutions per minute this
rotation along with the induced current
on the rotor inside the generator
produces voltage completing the process
of generating electricity the generator
output is 24,000 volts which is stepped
up to as much as 500,000 volts for
transmission
[Music]
plant Miller uses a closed-loop
circulating water system that allows
water to be reused over and over one way
we use water is in the condenser where
steam enters from the turbine and
condenses back into water as it passes
over tubes filled with cool circulating
water which is chlorinated river water
from nearby mulberry Fork of the Warrior
River the condensed water moves into the
hot well where it reads the system to be
reheated turned back into steam and
continue its use throughout the plant
[Music]
let's take a closer look at the
circulating water the plant uses
starting at the cooling tower cool water
is pumped from the cooling tower basin
through large pipes to the condenser to
absorb most of the heat from the turbine
exhaust steam leaving us with warmer
water that must be cooled so the warmer
water is circulated back to the cooling
tower where it enters through riser
lines to the top of the cooling tower
fill as the water cascades down the
cooling tower fill material it's air
cooled allowing the heat to escape up
through the natural draft cooling tower
the cooled water is collected in the
cooling tower basin to be recirculated
back to the plant to condense more
turbine steam exhaust
[Music]
once combustion is complete the heavier
particles of ash called bottom ash fall
into the bottom of the boiler there the
bottom ash is crushed using clinker
grinders mixed with water and sluice to
the hydro bins where the water is
decanted and ash collected in dump
trucks and either sold or moved to
on-site storage
[Music]
while the heavier particles of ash fall
to the bottom of the Pointer the hot
flue gas containing finer particles of
fly ash naturally flows up to the top of
the boiler and around down and out
through the back pass section the last
section of the boiler is the economizer
because of the shape and the flue gas
flow path some of the fly ash falls out
here into hoppers this economizer ash is
pulled by vacuum mixed and sluiced with
water to the ash booster station where
it is moved to on-site storage flue gas
a byproduct of combustion exits the
boiler and enters the selective
catalytic reduction oxide compounds the
flue gas then passes across the air
heater where over 400 degrees of
temperature are transferred from the
exiting flue gas to preheat the primary
and secondary air entering the plant
next the flue gas passes through the
precipitators where a negative charge is
induced onto the fine particles of ash
contained in the flue gas that ash is
then collected with an opposing charged
collecting plate these plates are then
shaken by vibrating wrappers causing the
ash to fall off into hoppers at the
bottom of the precipitator the ash is
then pulled with a vacuum to a
collection facility for Seiler storage
the flue gas then passes through the
induced draught fans and to the scrubber
where booster fans pull the flue gas
from the plant and push it through the
scrubber absorber in the absorber flue
gas mixes with water and limestone the
limestone reacts with and removes about
98% of sulfur dioxide
creating the byproduct of gypsum the wet
flue gas exits out the top of the
absorber through to the wet stack and a
gypsum slurry stream is pulled from the
bottom of the absorber and sent through
a dewatering facility inside the
dewatering facility most of the moisture
is removed from the gypsum so it can be
sold for use in wallboard
[Music]
when the power leaves the plant we
increase or step up the voltage for
transmission purposes to as much as five
hundred thousand volts to help minimize
losses from the transmission of power
our transmission group is responsible
for the large transmission lines towers
and substations that handle the large
voltage transfer of power over long
distances our distribution group
interacts with our customers more
directly and handles delivery of the
power in lower voltages stepped down in
substations and delivered to industrial
commercial and residential customers in
various voltages to suit their needs it
is our responsibility to provide our
customers with reliable affordable and
clean energy for their needs and we take
that very seriously we hope you enjoyed
this virtual tour of plant Miller
[Music]
so one problem that coal-fired power
plants
still have is they don't know what to do
with all of the ash that's left over
when they're done burning the coal so in
that video they talked about fly ash so
ash is just you know if you had a
fireplace and you burn some wood you got
leftover ash in the bottom when you're
done right
and so there's technology in that
coal-fired power plant to keep the ash
from flying out the chimney that's what
they call fly ash and flies out right
but there's ash left in the bottom and
they have to do something with it and if
they're burning you know multiple trains
full of coal a day they're generating a
lot of ash so in this picture here you
can see it looks like this muddy area
this is coal ash and they have to keep
it wet so it doesn't blow away and they
actually don't really know what to do
with it so this big area right out in
here is a pond and so they you know they
take a shot of the furnace they dump it
into this big pond where it stays wet
eventually settles down and here's an
here's an example of one of these ash
reservoirs so they're dumping ash into
this water you can kind of see there's
an outlet here so some of its going out
into the river there's regulations in
this country as to how much ash can get
into the river system and our current
administration has been trying to weaken
those regulations so that coal power
plants can can add more to the rivers
than they have in the past I don't know
where that'll go and people were trying
to figure out what to do with all this
ash can we like mix it in concrete to
get rid of it we make something out of
it usually it's just buried so this
whole field here is all coal ash and
there are some event where there's a big
erosion here but all this dark stuff you
see is coal ash right they just kept
dumping and dumping in this field and
they had kept it wet and kept it wet and
they finally got something to grow on it
and really they just thought of a
solution they don't know what to do with
all of it there's been a couple of
disasters where coal ash has leaked out
from reservoir and there's a big
disaster
about 10 years ago in Tennessee where
one of these coal ash reservoirs broke
about 1:00 in the morning all of this
wet gooey coal ash comes out and goes
through town there's chunks of roads in
the hair it's kind of hard to see but
this is all muddy
coal ash that went through a town wiped
out some houses comes down gets in the
river gets carried downstream so there's
a lot of places in the United States
where coal ash is becoming a problem
this is a few years old now but this is
a map showing the yellow dots are places
where there are these waste ponds these
reservoirs that have coal ash sitting in
them staying wet places that are orange
are recognized as having a high hazard
potential of having a leak or a failure
and then the red ones or places where
there was some sort of failure or gotten
to the groundwater or something like
that happen so what you see here is
there's a lot of red dots out here but
of course there's just a lot more coal
fire power plants out here because
there's a lot more coal out here the
eastern part of the country has the
majority of the cold fire power plants
so they have the most coal ash and
therefore they have the most coal ash
related problems now we could burn
natural gas instead of coal and one
advantage of doing that is natural gas
has a much cleaner fuel to burn it's
cleaner in that it produces less
greenhouse gases than coal does now coal
produces all kinds of stuff produces co2
ash etc if I burn natural gas
I still get co2 but I get less of it and
there's no leftover ash product and we
don't have piles of coal everywhere so
all you have to do is you have to have a
pipe that takes the the the natural gas
from wherever came from so if you live
in Albuquerque the natural gas probably
came from somewhere around Carlsbad and
down the pipe that we talked about in
the past and it comes to a power plant
and here's for example you can see
there's four chimneys here there's four
turbines
and so they burn they burn it spins a
turbine just just like the coal does and
generates electricity that way here's
another one but what you don't see here
is you don't see the piles of coal and
all the apparatus for that so when we
talk about electricity there's some
vocabulary and some math that we gotta
get into and ultimately what we're
trying to do is calculate what we call
carbon footprint so where we're headed
in this class is if I do something like
I turn on an appliance for a certain
amount of time how much co2 did I
produce that's where we're headed with
all this okay so to get there there's a
couple things that we've got to know one
is energy and one is power and they're
related to each other and that power is
how much energy you use over the time
that you use it and you can think of
this as a rate of energy consumption now
a physicist does not like to use the
term consuming energy or using energy we
don't really talk about that way we
convert energy from one form to another
but in everyday language we talk about
things like I'm going to use energy or
waste energy right but just to be clear
we're just converting it from one form
to another but verbally we say things
that are different than that and I will
too because that's how we talk so rate
of energy consumption is power it's how
fast are using the energy and the unit
that we use for this is called the Wat
Hey so James Watt he's a guy that helped
develop the steam engine back in the
1700s and so his last name is used today
as a unit of power and one watt means
you're using one Joule of energy per
second
now that probably has no meaning to you
either because what's a jewel and that's
a unit that if you're a physicist that
would make sense to you what a jewel is
but it's not something we have in
everyday use but if you think about
taking an apple and lifting it one meter
off the ground right so you pick it up
off the ground one meter that's about a
Joule of energy it took you a Joule of
energy to do that
so one watt would mean do you use it one
Joule of energy for every second right
okay so this is power and you've heard
of this because for one thing you may
have heard in terms of lightbulbs right
so you might hear something like a
hundred watt light bulb right you may
have heard of it that way or some guys
can tell you that they have a you know
thousand watt stereo right so that is it
you know another place you may have
heard about it if you have a hairdryer
on the side and I have a number like
1300 or 1350 those are that's its rating
and Watts so watts is something you
probably have heard of before and this
is all power it's how you a 100 watt
light bulb means it uses a hundred
joules of energy of electricity every
second that's what it means a thousand
watt stereo is capable of using a
thousand joules a second all right so
energy is the converse of this power
times time so I'm just taking this
formula and rewriting it solving it it's
the same exact formula but here's how we
we would do this let's imagine that I've
got a 60 watt light bulb and I have it
on for let's say four hours how much
energy did I use again we're using the
word use energy consumed energy whatever
we're converting it from one form to the
other but blah blah blah we know that
okay so what do we do math is easy 60
watts
times four hours and 60 times four is
240 now I've got the unit of watts I got
a unit of hours and when they multiply
these two together we write it as what
time's our so this what our is by itself
the unit of energy okay
so in physics there's a bunch of
different units of energy the one we're
going to use in this class and the only
one we're gonna use in this class is
something called the watt hour how many
watts times how many hours you take that
watt times that our it becomes watt hour
that's it's like its own thing the watt
hour it's not watts per hour that would
be divided by its Watts times hour okay
so verbal you'd say this 240 watt hours
that's how you would say it okay so
that's what that means now let's do
another example and let's say I now have
I've got a hundred watt light bulb and
let's say it's a porch light and I turn
it on and I just leave it on okay so
it's on for 24 hours a day and I'd like
to know how much energy I'm using in a
week energy used in one week okay so
energy the formula that we just had less
power times time okay so power is always
in watts time is always in hours and
sometimes you've got to do a little math
to figure out what your total hours are
so in this case my energy is somewhat so
Energy's power to assign power is 100
watts okay so what's my time gonna be
well it's on 24 hours a day
but it's on for a week right so there's
seven days in a week so I multiply that
by seven okay so I've got a hundred
watts times 24 times seven so let me do
that real quick
100 times 24 times seven equals sixteen
thousand eight hundred now my units are
watt hours okay 16 thousand eight
hundred watt hours now if you have over
a thousand watt hours we're going to
we're going to alter that unit a little
bit okay if I have over a thousand the
convention that we do is we divide by a
thousand and add a K in front of it so
if I have over a thousand watt hours I'm
going to divide the answer by a thousand
and then add a little K to the unit all
right it's like this so sixteen thousand
eight hundred watt hours it's over a
thousand so I'm then divided by a
thousand and I get sixteen point eight
and I know that add k2 watt hours all
right so the way that verbally reads is
16.8 kilowatt hours but people got tired
of writing all that out so there's an
abbreviation for the kilowatt hours
it's called K WH and this is called when
we talk about a kWh we say verbally you
is a kilowatt-hour that's how we say it
a kilowatt hour and the kilowatt hour is
the worldwide standard for measuring
electrical energy okay so outside your
house you have a kilowatt hour meter
because this is how the power company
charges you for the electricity that you
use so here's an old-school one that's
got the dials on it right and the guys
come over and there's this you know this
disc spins right here and the more
electricity you use the faster it spins
and these dials tell somebody how many
kilowatt hours yeah you have used since
the last time the meter reader person
came out and took a reading and then
you're charged by your kilowatt hours so
notice that this meter actually spells
out kilowatt hours and this one just
says kWh right so when you're charged by
the electric company so for example
around here it's usually PNM is our
electric company you will get charged
per kilowatt hour right so a rate
depends on kind of where you live but
maybe somewhere between on the low end
maybe eight cents - depending on where
you live may be as high as 30 cents per
kilowatt hour so we're going to learn
how to calculate a carbon footprint
which just means how much carbon are we
putting into the atmosphere when we do
different things and we're focusing in
this class on electricity cuz it's kind
of the easiest one to deal with so let's
imagine that all of my electricity is
being generated
by coal and so if I do an activity let's
say I leave a light on for a certain
number of hours or TV on for a certain
number of hours I want to know how much
coal had to be burned to do that and as
a result how much carbon got into the
atmosphere because of that okay so there
are modern coal-fired power plants there
are older Coldfire power plants they're
not all the same efficiency but when you
look at all of them roughly it comes out
that to generate one kilowatt hour to
generate one kilowatt hour of
electricity with coal you need to burn
one kilogram or about 2.2 pounds of coal
and that's about the size of a big
shoebox right so imagine kind of
extra-large shoebox full of coal that's
about how much you need okay so the
problems that we're gonna have are all
kind of the same format which is that
we'll have a scenario we want to know
how much coal is going to be burned and
then we're going to figure out from that
how much co2 is produced so it turns out
that when you burn one kilogram of coal
that you will produce two kilograms of
co2 gas or if I burn 2.2 pounds to put
it in our unit system we get 4.4 pounds
of co2 so in other words I get more co2
out of the chimney then the amount of
coal that I put in why would that be
because the call reacts when you burn
the coal it reacts with oxygen in the
air to produce more co2 so so one
kilogram of coal
to kilograms of co2 all right
that's we're talking about mass of a gas
which is abstract cuz we don't think
about gases is having mass but they do
so how much would that be if I had what
if I had two kilograms of co2 like how
much is that right if you could see it
and if you could see it it would be it
could feel cube that's about one meter
on a side so we call that one cubic
meter and one cubic meter is about one
thousand liters okay so think if I for
every kilowatt hour that I use in
electricity I have to burn one kilogram
of coal which makes two kilograms of co2
which would fill up a thousand liters of
co2 gas okay so that's those are the
numbers we've been using this class to
do the problems but they're all kind of
similar so here's an example so let's
say I have a TV that uses 330 watts and
I have this TV on let's say six hours a
day all right and let's say I do this
every single day for a month so we'll
say 30 days okay so here's the scenario
how much ultimately here's what I want
to know how much co2 did I put in the
atmosphere because of this right so to
answer that we've got to figure out how
many kilowatt hours how much coal and
how much co2 then it all starts on these
problems with figuring out the kilowatt
hours if you know the kilowatt hours you
can get to all the other things you need
to solve for all right so that's we're
going to do first we're going to figure
out how much energy did
this take so energy is power times time
what's my power 330 watts what's my time
okay so it's got to be in hours it's six
hours a day but I'm doing this for 30
days so my total hours is 6 times 30 so
it's multiply all that out so I've got
330 oops
330 times 6 times 30 equals 59400 what
hours okay so 4000 divided by a thousand
turn it into kilowatt hours so I'm gonna
divide by a thousand and that gives me
fifty nine point four kWh all right this
is what we need to do the rest
so for every kill we see in the
beginning for every kilowatt hour I need
to burn one kilogram or 2.2 pounds of
coal so let's say I ask you pounds of
coal how many pounds of coal did I have
to burn in that month right so I take my
fifty nine point four kilowatt hours
times two point two pounds oops 2.2
pounds of coal for every kilowatt hour
so I just take that number fifty nine
point four times two point two and I get
130 point seven pounds so that's how
many pounds of coal I had to burn that
month for my TV so how much co2 did I
make well if I ask for say pounds of co2
then I would go back to my
fifty nine point fifty nine point four
kilowatt hours times four point four so
I get four point four pounds of co2 for
every kilowatt hour and now I can just
take the one I just got and I get two
sixty one point four pounds of co2
so that's pounds of a gas how many
liters is that I go back to the kilowatt
hours and multiply by a thousand so if I
go back to how many liters of co2 then I
go back to my kilowatt hours which is
fifty nine point four times a thousand
liters per every kilowatt hour and
that's pretty easy math 59400 liters of
co2 so in all these problems you go back
to the kilowatt hours and multiply that
by two point two or one or a thousand
depending on what your what you're
trying to solve for or what if the cost
financial cost let's say you're charging
me eleven cents a kilowatt hour how much
money does that cost me to run my TV per
month I take fifty nine point four
kilowatt hours times eleven cents per
kilowatt hour and fifty nine point four
times point one one and I get six
dollars and 53 cents so if you compare
these two things the financial cost in
this country is very low to generating
fifty nine point four kilowatt hours
that's actually quite a bit of
electricity if you had to do that
manually by cranking something I mean it
would take you weeks of work
to do this only costs us $6.50 and yet
it produces close to sixty thousand
liters of co2 into the atmosphere so
this is one of the problems that we deal
with in environmental science that there
is a financial cost which is not very
big and there's an environmental cost
which can be huge
nobody's paying for this upfront right
we pay for this but this is really the
cost that we're worried about in in this
class okay so let's do another example
let's say I've got a 60 watt let's see
let's say I got 60 watt porch light in
the front and I got a hundred watt porch
light in the back of my house alright so
one in the front one in the back and
they're on 24 hours a day how much coal
do I need to burn for these just these
two light bulbs in a year so I got to
get my kilowatt hours first
okay what's my power I've got 60 water
and 100 water what's my time 24 hours
all year long times 365 so that gives me
160 watts times 24 times 365 hours so i
have 160 times 24 times 365 I get 1
million 400 1600 watt hours okay
I got divided by thousand to turn it
into kilowatt hours so divided by
thousand and I get 1400 1.6 kilowatt
hours and this is remember for the whole
year how many pounds of coal let's say I
ask that question so so what we said is
if you know your kilowatt hours multiply
that by 2.2 so I take one thousand four
hundred and one kilowatt hours 2.2
pounds so one thousand four hundred and
one point six times two point two and I
get three thousand eighty three point
five pounds of coal oops
pounds of coal
all right liters of co2 I go back to my
kilowatt hours
and it's a thousand liters for every
kilowatt hour so that gets me 1 million
for 1600 liters the co2
how about cost let's say it costs 13
cents kilowatt hour then I go back to my
kilowatt hours 1401 point 6 times 13
cents 1401 point 6 times 0.1 3 I get
$182 and 21 cents ok so that's the cost
in terms of financial and the cost in
terms of the environmental of leaving
those two light bulbs on 24 hours a day
so these problems can get more and more
complicated but it's the same math every
time its power times time so we'll do
one more that's slightly more
complicated so you can see how you might
do something like this so we could have
a scenario such as this I've got a 60
watt porch light and it's on for 12
hours a day 12 hours a day I have a 210
watt TV it's on for 4 hours a day inside
I have two 120 watt lamps they are on
for 6 hours a day
what is my
carbon footprint for the year
okay so we're assuming the same usage
every day so what does carbon footprint
mean how much coal did I burn how much
co2 co2 did I produce alright so same
math energy is power times time I guy
add it all up and do all the math so I
can do a piecewise so in other words I
can say all right let's do the porch
lights I've got 60 watts times 12 hours
times 365 days a year I've got the TV
the TV is 210 watts times 4 hours times
365 I got the lamps I've got 120 watt
lamps but there's two of them and
they're on for six hours a day times 365
ok so so I'm just dividing each one of
these up each time power times time and
I can do each one and then add them all
up so 60 times 12 times 365 I get 2
moves 260 2800 watt hours for the TVs I
get 210 times four times three six two
five three hundred six thousand six
hundred watt hours and for the lamps I
get home 20 times two times six times
365 525,600 watt hours now
what I'm going to do is go ahead and and
divide each of those by a thousand and
turn them into kWh so that gift
gets me to sixty two point eight KW h 3o
6.6 kWh five twenty five point six kwh
add them all up take my two sixty two
point eight plus three o six point six
plus five twenty five point six equals
thousand ninety five kilowatt hours per
year okay so now if I said all right how
much how many kilograms of coal would we
have to burn for this so then we'll do a
couple here so kilograms of coal well I
can take that many kilowatt hours
thousand ninety-five one kilogram one
kilogram of co2 oops I'm sorry one
kilogram of coal for every kilowatt hour
means I get one thousand that thousand
ninety five kilograms of coal alright
that's pretty easy calculation you're
just multiplying by one right well if I
said pounds of coal all right then I got
a thousand ninety five kilowatt hours
times 2.2 pounds per coal sorry
pounds per kilowatt-hour so I just take
that multiply that by two point two and
you get 24 oh nine pounds of coal or
what if I said how many liters of co2 I
go back to my kilowatt hours and
multiply that by a thousand thousand
liters per kilowatt hour and I get 109
500 so a million 95 thousand liters a
co2 okay etc right so so that the
problems are all of the similar nature
get it to kilowatt hours multiply it by
one of those factors get the answer